fut de voir les problèmes qui se pose
est celui de d'assumer ses
responsabilités patrick pleau c'est le
début de la fin pour anne hidalgo c'est
compliqué ça semblait compliqué ça fait
un peu dispute du vieux couple quoi
voilà je sais pas ce qu'il faut en tirer
comme conclusion parce que j'ai lu
l'interview comme vous et en fait c'est
très flou les reproches qui sont donnés
par contre concrètement on peut pas dire
que ce qui se passe dans paris soit
actuellement en sympathique
les exemples qui donne moi je suis
diplômé le naufrage total des vélib
après la conséquence sur les autolib où
il y aurait de 160 millions d'euros de
déficits etc
on se demande ce qui ce qui fabrique
c'est un peu ça le problème
c'est un peu ça alors maintenant est ce
que c'est un coup politique de julliard
pour partir avec la république en marche
qui va présenter des candidats pour les
municipales est ce que ça je ne sais pas
étant parisien comme vous la vie à paris
et rendu un peu compliqué on s'arrête on
a beaucoup critiqué à l'idéal go jusqu'à
présent mais c'était plutôt les gens de
l'extérieur il t'arrive au figaro
magazine de faire des couvertures qui
était pas forcément complètement
positive sur la gestion de d'anne
hidalgo
mais cette fois ci le la taxe vient du
coeur du système est d'ailleurs julliard
dit à peu près ce que disaient les gens
qui jusqu'à présent critique et anne
hidalgo
absolument c'est ça qui est ça qui me
frappe c'est que je trouve au contraire
que ces reproches sont extrêmement
précises très circonstancielle il lui
reproche son absence d'efficacité et
surtout et avant tout et ce qui peut
être là régime ccc de cette action
dictée par l'idéologie et finalement
anne hidalgo c'est l'histoire d'un auto
sabotage et 7
elle était l'héritière naturelle delanoë
tout tout tout l'effet était à ce moment
des boudins avait réussi à séduire les
beaux mots sans se mettre à dos les
beaux quartiers
et puis
et elle par l'idéologie et puis il faut
bien dire par cette gestion difficile
qualifié de la mairie de paris qui
équipe une hausse qui se résume par une
série d'échecs a mis tout ça
abba en quelques années le la vie des
tweetos est assez sombre
aussi nous vous posons la question sur
le hashtag figaro live la démission de
son premier adjoint bruno julliard
marque-t-elle le début de la fin pour
anne hidalgo et vous êtes 78 % à
considérer que oui
du côté de la mairie de la majorité
parisienne pour l'instant c'est plutôt
le silence radio
on a quand même réussi à vous trouver
une réaction c'est celle du président du
groupe des élus écologistes au conseil
de paris
il s'appelle david belliard et lui dit
bah oui effectivement ce pas une bonne
nouvelle
m'enfin quand même on s'y attendait
regardez le voyait au quotidien une
difficulté à travailler ensemble
un effacement progressif du premier
adjoint donc non je peux pas dire que
c'était une surprise par contre oui
c'est un coup dur pour cette majorité
c'est un coup dur aussi pour la maire de
paris je pense qu'il faut le dire du
moins ce que anne hidalgo n'a que ce
qu'elle mérite ou est-ce que vous allez
lui trouver quelques circonstances
atténuantes j'aurais du mal parce que
j'ai il suffit d'écouter la série de
litanie de gens qui se plaignent d'anne
hidalgo
au début c'était les
l'opinion publique l'opposition on a eu
aussi ce séjourne ces deux journalistes
qui ont sorti ce les dernières se
livrent notre drame de paris qui est
très intéressant et maintenant le cercle
se rapproche ce sont les les plus
proches collaborateurs il ya eu julien
bargeton qui est parti vers en marche et
maintenant c'est bruno julliard sur le
fond je pense que vous l'avez dit l
idéologue
elle est aussi cassantes sectaire et la
gestion c'est catastrophique
je pense qu'on est d'entrer encore
jusqu'à ce soir si on devait épeler
toute la litanie des échecs de d'anne
hidalgo
moi je voudrais quand même en souligné 1
parce que c'est quand même énorme c'est
cette histoire de marchés publics
illégaux avec jean claude decaux qui ont
coûté à fric fou aux contribuables parce
que c'est quand même dingue absence de
mise en concurrence puis elle n'écoute
quand on dit quand bruno julliard dit
elle n'écoute personne c'est vrai la
direction des affaires juridiques de la
mairie de paris avait dit non mais ne
signe et surtout pas se contrôler elle
le signe et donc du coup je pense que
maintenant dans son entourage tout le
monde se dit mais c'est tout sauf
hidalgo et du coup je pense qu'elle
serait bien avisé de retourner à
l'inspection du travail ou d'ailleurs
elle va pas fait grand chose entre 2001
et 2002 on pourrait en parler ça notre
sujet ce que vous même vous avez
travaillez vous avait d'ailleurs
collaboré à ce livre dont je parlais
avec charles beigbeder qui est
conseiller municipal d'opposition dont
il est marrant des fossiles municipal
d'opposition divers droite divers droite
vous parliez notre dame de paris le
nôtre drame de paris ce livre dont le
figaro magazine a publié les bonnes
feuilles moment de sa sortie
et à l'époque la seule réaction de la
mairie de paris ça avait été de nous
dire vous êtes homophobe alors on n'a
pas très bien compris pourquoi c'est
parce qu'effectivement il ya un certain
nombre d'adjoints au tour d'anne hidalgo
qui ne font pas mystère de leur
orientation sexuelle qui est leur
affaire mais on n'avait absolument pas
parler de ce sujet évidemment et pour
cause
et on avoue qu'on était resté sans voix
devant ce tel argument ferghana ziari
mais ce n'est pas la première fois à
dalgo adore se poser en victime chaque
fois que l'on combine aussi parce que je
suis une fée exactement m'a taclé comme
une infâme donc on m'attaque parce que
je ne suis une femme nous il ya aussi
des femmes qui vous critiquent parce que
votre bilan n'est sans doute pas aussi
bon que vous le prétendez donc on a
rappelé ici des les les fiascos
financiers vélib autolib les récents
déboires de la mairie de paris avec les
problèmes du rite rotois ray et toutes
ces choses font que finalement la
démission de monsieur julliard ma vie
c'est simplement à l' approche des
élections de ne pas se mouiller et de ne
pas assumer en fait le bilan parce que
ils sont peut-être ils sont sans doute
la sanction électorale pointer et il ne
veut pas être là le jour où cette
sanction ça pique
des réactions sur les réseaux sociaux
pour béatrice hidalgo a trop de
casseroles entre les quais de seine les
rats effectivement on en avait fait
encore parler
les urinoirs c'est de ces nouveaux
dispositifs qui ne font pas l'unanimité
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire les
poubelles la saleté ce que confirme
haleine sur twitter en affirmant que la
politique de la ville de paris est très
loin des véritables préoccupations
ddd parisien laurence de charette
comment est-ce qu'on peut expliquer
cette espèce de l'enfermement d'un
hidalgo parce qu'après tout si elle
avait reconnu ses erreurs elle aurait pu
rebondir parce que elle est assez proche
sociologiquement de ce que penser de ce
que sont les parisiens sur l'écologie
par exemple
oui hélas le vivre ensemble à lyon feu
alors moi je
je l'analyse psychologique d'allouer pas
pas évidente
il ya une entrée par sa part la
novlangue sa langue résume son
sectarisme
chaque mot est extrêmement compliquée la
façon de nommer les choses les temps la
politique n'a pas pu sa novlangue
illustre son sectarisme
parce qu'il peut encore rebondir ça va
être très difficile
ça va être très difficile parce que moi
ce qui est ce que ce que je trouve
intéressant avec ce genre de personnage
politique c'est finalement elle avait
une espèce de boulevard devant elle elle
était portée par l'élan parce que
delanoë six étaient représentés ils
auraient été réélu delanoë avait eu un
il a eu un succès en tant que père de
paris née encore populaire on voit dans
les sondages etc et elle a tout cassé
en fait et c'est la culture du pouvoir
qu'est-ce qu'il fait que d'un coup ces
femmes et ces hommes politiques qui
combattent pour obtenir le pouvoir d'un
coup oublient leurs électeurs oubli
pourquoi ils ont été élus
et finalement kas l'objet sur lequel ils
sont comme dit fort justement madame qui
avec un langage qui est un petit peu au
dessus avec des choses qui ceux qui sont
compliquées on le voit par exemple avec
la circulation dans paris où on se c'est
pas qu'on baisse la circulation
des automobiles c'est qu'on empêche tout
le monde de circuler mais y compris les
obstacles qu'il ya sur les trottoirs
c'est quand même assez incroyable enfin
comme vous vous allez vous promener à
new york à rome à londres les trottoirs
sont dégagées à paris il ya de plus en
plus de d'obstacles ggc très compliqué
pour les personnes malvoyantes de
circuler par exemple dans paris bon bah
tout ça pour l'exprimer le dire à la
mairie alors ils ont fait des
consultations participative etc
mais c'est on sait pas où ça va en fait
tout ça c'est compliqué à mieux l'âme
dans un autre monde
c'est au fond vous parlez de viry
trottoir on pourrait parler du clip
grotesque pas pipi dans paris voilà où
va l'argent des contribuables cirque eux
avaient complètement mon cousin qui
n'auraient pas suivi il ya effectivement
un clip qui tourteaux les réseaux
sociaux qui s'appelle pas pipi dans
paris pour essayer de dissuader sa
légende piste dans la rue et le tout et
supposait du troisième degré c'est
probablement juste et le betis suis
d'accord mais écoutez on est tombé dans
un tel niveau bien respect de notre
société que ce clip est à la hauteur de
la bêtise de nos compatriotes qui fait
pipi n'importe où qui jettent n'importe
quoi on va on va revenir qui sont
photons bail et revenir tout à l'heure
sur l'eau le mien parce que je suis
intarissable là dessus c'est n'importe
quoi
le clip le clip mariage mais il faut
écoute on est dans une culture de masse
il faut réapprendre aux gens à vivre
ensemble et ça ça si ce clip ridicule un
peu et d adapter son nom mais c'est pas
ça si l'on peut appeler ça le respect à
plessala la moralisation ce que vous
voulez a pris le comme vous voulez si
vous ne vous le donne simplement faut
faire quelque chose parce que l'aller
les gens font n'importe quoi
c'est en matière de neuf langues bruno
julliard a été la bonne et à bonne école
parce que quelqu'un normal aurait dit
anne hidalgo a un problème avec les gens
qui pensent pas comme elle est bien lui
il dit j'y vois pour ma part un mort un
manque d'authenticité dans le rapport à
l'altérité démocratique ça si ça te
reviendra mais pratique
ziari c'est incompréhensible voilà voilà
le clip 1 / 2 / pas de pas de pipi dans
paris c'est alors voilà qu'on est en
train de vous mais pas le son mais
croyez moi c'est pas triste non plus
ferghana ziari un conseil à donner à
l'idéal go pour qu'elle essaie de
remonter la pente
je ne vois pas honnêtement j'aurais
tendance à dire peut-être laissé deux
parlements départ devant le clip
j'avais pas vu vous a coupé la parole
faire guardian on essaie de faire le
moins de quatre heures possible
peut-être d'ici l'échéance électorale de
2020 ça c'est pas mal alors quelques
réactions sur les réseaux sociaux des
internautes qui sont en train de nous
regarder pour béatrice avant ça on a
déjà dit et allen sur twitter oui qui
dit la politique de la ville est trop
loin des véritables préoccupations des
parisiens le commentaire nous dit il
aurait mieux valu pas de rats dans paris
ou pas de pickpockets dans paris plutôt
que pas de plutôt que pas de pipi et
puis
voilà d'autres d'autres réactions qui
sont globalement assez négative beaucoup
plus je voudrais pas qu'on enfonce trop
ce pauvre anne hidalgo don va passer au
sujet suivant jean michel blanquer
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
donné une interview au figaro de ce
matin dans laquelle il y avait deux deux
annonces qui sont pas passées inaperçues